the united nations is pushing for the
release of 16 ethiopian staff who've
been detained by the government in addis
ababa un and humanitarian sources say
they were arrested during government
raids targeting
72 drivers for the world food programme
have also been arrested
as far as i know no
explanation given to us about why these
these staff members are
are detained
um
they
there are 16 remaining
in detention
and six have been released
so that that's the the the breakdown uh
they come from various uh u.n agencies
they're all
national staff
um
it is imperative that they uh that they
be released
al jazeera's mohamed ado is in addis
ababa foreign muhammad the the unm world
food programme staff who have been
detained has the government's uh
explained why
these staff members have been detained
what more do we know
well hello yes we can confirm that they
are
figuring
ethnically and not just the 16 staff
members who have been detained in addis
ababa but also the more than 70 drivers
working for the world food programme
the government
officials are saying that they have been
involved in terrorism which is a thinly
veiled accusation that they've been
working with the tigrayan fighters who
are fighting the ethiopian defense
forces
um
there's been a massive swoop not just in
addis ababa but across the country by
ethiopian police targeting
ethnic tigrans
and they've been accusing them of just
that terrorism
because the tplf is considered a terror
organization by the government and has
been one of the things that has been
holding negotiations between the
government and the rebels so far
that's all we can we know right now
what is interesting is that um un
workers in the course of fulfilling
their duties enjoy
a certain level of immunity according to
international protocols
why this has not that this has not been
respected uh still no one knows
well mohammed what does this mean for
the diplomatic efforts to try and bring
the two sides and the conflict together
because this looks like a significant
escalation if uh to grind members of
un staff
are being detained are both sides
willing to negotiate at this stage
yes and uh
we have to point out that the u.n
workers who've been arrested because of
their ethnicity are just a tiny fraction
of the hundreds
uh if not thousands of others who have
been detained
and who belong to
the tigray ethnicity
um of course this is going to have a
huge impact already the international
community led by the united states have
been condemning
targeting people based on their
ethnicity
um
the diplomatic efforts are still going
on despite this uh olusegun obasa and
your former president of nigeria is
leading the efforts by the african union
um
has been
to mckellen where he has met the top
leadership of the tplf he has also
traveled to the amahara and the alpha
regions where the conflict has built
over to in recent weeks and where most
of the intensive fighting has been going
on obasanjo believes that there is a
small window of opportunity to bring the
two parties in the conflict to the
negotiating table
he says he will have a plan by the end
of the week uh also carrying out a
similar but parallel initiative with
jeffrey feltman the us
special envoy to the horn of africa he's
back in addis ababa uh just days after
leaving
for neighboring kenya
um and both the united states and the
african union say they have been
talking and comparing notes uh and
something that gives that a boost is a
tweet by the prime minister on late on
tuesday when he said that the east
government was ready to work with
ethiopia's friends to see that ethiopia
goes through what he called the
temporary challenges it's going through
okay muhammad
reporting live from addis ababa for now
mo thank you very much indeed